one of the the main features of the
language I say so fully ingest is that
it allows you to have the file extension
to be uh an emoji or the fire Emoji
which is
one of the first
emojis used as a file extension I've
ever seen in my life and then you ask
yourself the question why in the 21st
century are we not using Unicode for
file extensions so I mean it's an epic
decision I think clearly the most
important decision you made the most but
but you could also just use mojo as the
file extension well so okay so take a
step back I mean come on Max do you
think that the world's ready for this
this is a big moment in the world right
this is we'll release this onto the
world this is innovation
I mean it really is kind of brilliant
emojis is such a big part of our daily
lives why is it not in programming well
and and like you take a step back and
look look at what file extensions are
right they're basically metadata right
and so why are we spending all the
screens based on them and all the stuff
also you know you have them stacked up
next to text files and PDF files and
whatever else like if you're gonna do
something cool you want to stand out
right and emojis are colorful they're
visual they're they're beautiful right
what's been their response so far from
uh is is there support on like Windows
on the operating system in displaying
like file explorer yeah the one problem
I've seen is the git doesn't escape it
right and so it thinks that the fire
Emoji is unprintable and so it like
prints out weird hex things if you use
the command line git tool but everything
else as far as a warrior works fine and
I I have faith that git can be improved
so yeah so GitHub is fine GitHub is fine
yep GitHub is fine Visual Studio code
Windows like all this stuff totally
ready because people will have
internationalization yeah in their
normal part of their past
so let's just like taking the next step
right
somewhere between oh wow that makes
sense cool I like new things too
oh my God you're killing my baby like
what are you talking about this could
never be like I can never handle this
how am I going to type this this is just
like all these things and so this is
something where I think that the world
will get there we don't have to bet the
whole Farm on this I think we can
provide both paths but I think it'll be
great uh when can we have emojis as part
of the code I wonder uh yeah so I mean
lots of languages provide that so um I
think that we have personal support for
that it's probably not fully done yet
but but yeah you can you can do that for
example in Swift you can do that for
sure so an example we give gave it Apple
was the the dog cow yeah so that's a
classical Mac Heritage thing and so he's
the dog and the cow emoji together and
that could be your variable name but of
course the internet went and made pile
of poop for everything yeah so you know
if you want to name your function pile
of poop then you can totally go to town
and see how that gets through code
review